when you're single though you miss love
it's nice to have love it's nice to have
someone love you that's nice but that's
the thing
we all want the love but nobody wants to
do the work that's what the love part
yeah
it's kind of like a dog walker we all
have our dog be a pace might do the
stuff you don't want to do pick up the
poop walk it would it be great to have a
girlfriend walker
just some guy on the sidewalk with eight
girlfriends on a leash like all right
tell me about your day
yeah get mad about a dream you had
ask me something hypothetical about you
gaining weight
cry now cry now
then you get your girlfriend back like
did she cry took a while but she cried
yeah
oh yeah